hey you bozos do yourselves a favor come
out and see the boys live oh yeah stand
up comedy show we play a little ayg with
the crowd fantastic way to introduce new
people to the show so bring the whole
gang out come see us yeah guys get your
best gal friend your best boyfriend the
group chat your homies the bozos anybody
we're gonna be in red bank new jersey uh
in august that show's about to sell out
then we're going to seattle portland
kansas city springfield st louis
nashville indy philadelphia providence
rhode island boston atlanta get those
tickets we'll see you there yeah welcome
to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out they grew up to be classy yeah
but they're just a big old piece of
trash i'm your host holy coming at you
on a beautiful day we're down here at
aunt tooty's basement she has
unfortunately come down with severe case
of covet and monkey pox okay is what
we're supposed to say for boss calls all
right all right very contagious my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me unamused this week what can i tell
you i'm doing my best here he is the ceo
of ru garbage international businessman
he is the prince of park avenue but
always the king of the boardwalk baby
give it up for my best pal kj hey kevin
james ryan hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always make sure you rate view
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube as you know those numbers are
true
[ __ ] cooking baby then obviously the
greatest [ __ ] website of all time
google get the [ __ ] out of the way
www.patreon.com
slash ru garbage sign up you get bonus
content episodes of ayg hard feelings
live streams the whole nine yards
[ __ ] do it it's a real good time over
there check it out having a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good he
works the ones and twos he crosses the
t's and he dots the eyes give it up for
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen everybody
what's up dudes what's up somebody oh
man summertime i'm feeling a little
southern barbecue in here a little
[ __ ] southern flavor it's gonna be a
good one very nice scan we couldn't be
more excited to have our incredibly
special guest here with this today for
the first time he is a super duper funny
stand-up comedian the kid's a killer
he's a regular on kill tony tours with
joe rogan tours with louis c.k but the
big question about his mind today is he
garbage well the first thing he did when
he got to totties is drop a deuce
you all got a bathroom but we're gonna
go through the motions give it up for
david lucas everybody what's up y'all
thanks for coming dude
yeah man that slice of pepperoni got you
no
i had a slice of lasagna i could a
lasagna pizza i could turn that down
what are you doing
yeah man i hope roger don't watch this
episode
you don't think i'm a loser right i knew
you couldn't do it
but i guess one slice of pizza you're in
new york enjoy yourself yeah absolutely
man and i mean i'm walking like four or
five miles a day there you go you know
what i'm saying it's wild that everybody
he's on david's on tour right now yeah
you guys are driving everywhere yeah so
uh for this uh east coast tour i am
driving well last we saw you in l.a last
time we saw you we saw you in l.a i did
fly i didn't drive from there
but you were like i'm flying to pick up
the car then you're driving to
washington then new york
texas mississippi uh
that's somebody on the run from
something yeah that's [ __ ] crazy no
so uh
so i decided to bring all the kids and
my mom okay on tour this year wait
everybody's with you yeah yeah yeah
so i got uh we got a big car man
it's a coop
we got a a big car um so i decided to
bring the kids and my mom on the road
that's very part of summer that's very
nice i have my kids for the summer and
they hate when i
go and disappear for like three four
weeks at a time all right now that's
pretty close family man yeah i thought
it was you two and like some 96 cammy
with a with a pack of pork rinds yeah
and rolled out like [ __ ] white down
windows we paid 55 a park today right
now 55
we'll take
i don't like staying in the city so i
got to come with a slice of lasagna
pizza
it came with something yeah i don't like
staying in the city too much so i got a
house out in jersey bloomfield okay
pretty that couple of classy hits right
off the jump man
what is the back story of david lucas
give us the whole thing atlanta right
bacon making georgian georgia uh my dad
is uh cuban he was adopted um
my mom she was a working class mom uh
you know my dad he eventually uh came to
do great things me him are not close but
that was later on in my life later on he
does cool [ __ ] i'm not i don't like him
yeah yeah me and him are still not close
man so you know um parents together no
okay they divorced when i was like 18
months
daddy had some bad addictions okay
he was very violent towards my mom okay
um yeah stuff like that so uh when they
got a divorce we want to go look at my
grandparents okay uh my grandparents did
live in the suburbs okay so it afforded
me the opportunity to go to a better
school okay than where me and my mom
were living uh so i was able you know to
be kind of a suburban kid okay even
though my mom was flexing on those
[ __ ] yeah yeah but it was kind of
hard man because like my grandparents
lived in a very affluent neighborhood
all right it was so weird like growing
up affluent these are her parents your
mom's parents right so they did well
right right my grenade did well uh my
grandmama didn't work my granny was just
a hard worker who saved a lot of money
and
granted that's old school yeah that's
southern [ __ ] my granddaddy was a hard
worker he was a hard worker he uh sounds
like a blues song
he ended up buying a few rental
properties all right i like that what
did he do for a living was he just like
he worked at a um what do you call i
guess it's like a textile plant okay
okay so they made like the little white
squares you see in office buildings
[Applause]
okay it was a company called armstrong
he worked there for a very okay time he
would go to work like and my granddaddy
was not a [ __ ] to be [ __ ] with
bro like he was almost like he was
semi-evil bro like for real
it was good and bad make the titles just
a little bit smaller so they fall
but it was good and bad um
you know living in my grandparents
household yeah very strict man like i
was in church three four times a week
damn uh he made me like i couldn't dress
wear like flash at the church it was
like straight white button up black
slacks black shoes type thing
um i remember i used to exclusively date
white girls in elementary and middle
because of where i live
the white girl is going to get you hung
like
it's like
granddaddy
but here's the thing
he married my grandmother who's half
white
like my granny was very racist towards
white people but he married a halfway
lady damn half white duck i guess there
you go that's how he gets in there
he had eight kids man um you know my
granddaddy bro he was
he was he there was no reasoning with
him uh it was
even this guy sounds [ __ ] awkward you
have to do chores and [ __ ] around the
house man bro i was pretty much bro like
it wasn't
it wasn't chores bro like
i remember when i turned like 15 16 and
i was able to drive and get a job it was
better to get a [ __ ] job than to do
this [ __ ]
yeah
yeah because he had rental properties
and he and i remember at one time he had
like five of them in a row and he would
drop me off with a gallon of water and
tell me i'll be back in three hours and
all this grass better be cut and pick up
all the paper no lawnmower what do you
do i had a lawnmower
i had a i had a lawn mower but it was
[ __ ] like that so i'm like yeah
and then he give me something like ten
dollars you know i don't work three
hours i get ten dollars i'm gonna leave
business man i had no cell phone this
was you know the 2000's you know it was
like 2 000 bro 2001 i had you cutting
the grass in the suit and in the hood
and this these were like hood areas
these were not like what the suburbs it
was like it wasn't the suburbs at all
these were he owned rental properties in
the hood and he dropped me off with a
gallon of water and a lawnmower and say
i'll be back in three hours there was no
if i finished early there was no calling
him because he didn't have a cell phone
so he'd come back whenever the hell he
felt like it yeah can't have people
tracking him you know he's out there
making moves yeah bro like that's my
granddaddy bro like like the only the
only memories i really have of him like
he died like two three years ago and me
and him we had a very like i guess you
can call like a little precarious
relationship yeah
yeah because when i got dropping you off
in the middle of nowhere man come on man
bottle of pole in the spring but um
yeah like you know like bro he was
like the memories i have with him is
like him like beating my ass you know
what i'm saying okay like a lot of kids
from the south got sure yeah [ __ ] i
don't know if you all got back oh we got
i got the [ __ ] kicked out i did it
i deserved it every time too no hard
feelings that [ __ ] beat out of me man
you know um and yeah bro he smoked
cigars have a tampa juel i still
remember him bro
uh yeah and uh i played a lot of sports
growing up uh mainly grew up around my
grandparents my mom worked a lot right
uh was the family was your mom's
brothers and sisters are they all in the
same area um so
we lived in uh what was called north
macon and my great-grandmother zania
walton who was my grandfather's mom
allocated property
to all of us because her daddy was like
she was a native american and her daddy
was black and white so her daddy was a
big-time businessman he brought a whole
bunch of property that he left to her
and then she left like i have property
in georgia now damn it's doing all right
so uh my family like there's an episode
on my youtube where i took bert kreicher
to macon when we did the tour and uh
like my whole family lives on one
private drive
private private yeah because otherwise
that's trash if everybody's everybody
just bought a house
each other yeah damn
like the rockefellers down there yeah i
mean you know like it's it's it's middle
class georgia living which doesn't take
a lot of money to achieve you know what
i'm saying like you could be middle
class in georgia making 40k a year like
you like you can still go get a two
bedroom apartment in macon georgia right
now for 1200 in a good neighborhood you
know so it you can go get a nice house
down there for 280 000 so it doesn't
when i go to macon bro i feel like
i'm just like yeah
i take i take my family out to eat every
day
every
attending applebee's again i'm talking
about like 10 people bro
i got everybody
free refills for everybody let's go what
i'm hoping i'm flexing at family dinner
i'm just saying like i live in l.a man
you know
me and my kids eat is a hundred dollars
you know so it's like i go home we can
go to [ __ ] fajitas which is my
favorite mexican restaurant i can feed
eight people for a hundred and thirty
dollars and that's with drinks
[Laughter]
that's bottomless margaritas my dude has
come out scissors
holy [ __ ] but i play i play sports
growing up um uh my mom so like in my
earlier years i didn't see too much of
my mom because she just worked way too
hard you know what i'm saying to try to
provide for me to have a good life this
is when you guys were on your own no we
i'm already at your grandparents yeah i
live yeah i live like i don't really
remember living alone my mom because we
moved in you were yeah you were always
with your grandparents how are you right
so i i um even though your mom lived
with you with her parents she was still
out there busting her ass yes and so she
had a house you know what i'm saying so
like the age of
when i was like five my grandmother had
a stroke and an aneurysm so my mom moved
in exclusively with my grandparents but
i was always at my grandparents house to
go to the better school you know what i
mean
so your mom lived in a different house
right so you were oh you was just you
and your granddad yeah yeah yeah you
wasn't even the buffer of your mom nah
damn that's like shawshank
christ so like i have like a very few
memories
like my mom if she had a day off she'd
pick me up and we'd like go to her house
but it was in the hood so i'd be like
man i'm gonna go back to my grandparents
you're there cutting the grass and [ __ ]
i mean i'm ready to go back to grandma
though like hey you gotta grab my like
tom where's the central air conditioner
what's going on in there so that
probably made her like sad man like like
my mom like now i say at my age now we
have a better relationship than when i
was a teenager sure just because she
worked so much she missed yeah my mom uh
miss me winning uh the state
championship and wrestling nice she
missed me uh winning uh the state
championship in football all because she
was working so hard okay but my
granddaddy did start coming to those
things so when i got like i'd say like
15 and people started noticing i was
good and uh sports like there was like a
paradigm shift like in my family because
like before that i felt like the black
sheep sure i was the the one kid who
whose daddy was not around you know what
i'm saying so the rest of my cousins
had you know the dual parents the mom
and the dad they had that dynamic of
their relationship so i was the one
who uh would get [ __ ] on a lot you
know like i'd be the butt of something
so if me and my other cousins are doing
something it's his fault you know what i
mean it's his fault he started throwing
fireman's carries and dropping throwing
people in full nelson's
[ __ ] [ __ ] so yeah like when i
started playing football i started
getting big you know what i'm saying
there you go there's no more of that
like you know
there's no more black sheep and then all
of a sudden
uh and there's really um
only one person in my family who
remained constant from the time i was a
kid
to like now and that's my uncle aubry
like like he's my what i would say is my
father figure gotcha you know what i'm
saying like that's the person i looked
up to gotcha i've always wanted to be
like him uh like i used to get my hair
cut like him and i always wanted a
relationship and a family like him he
wasn't beating your ass no he wasn't
being but i mean he he did offer
discipline but
yeah
so uh yeah he uh he works at the post
office down in macon georgia and i can
say he's my real father figure because
like
um growing up like that was the only
person who could really reason with me
you know okay yeah that was that like i
would listen to him before i listened to
my mom well you were were you a bad kid
were you getting in trouble
i went like
growing up not smart ass i was pretty i
was yeah i was very intelligent man like
i was i was uh you know like i was a
part of the beta club you know like uh
what's beta club it's a it's a
in the south it's like a club for kids
with high iqs
like an honors you're like an honest
person
i was published in the sixth grade you
know what i'm saying i had published
yeah i was published in a book in the
sixth grade you know so like i had i was
very intelligent what was the book
it was called uh budding arthurs it was
a a collection of stories from young
kids that had had high intellect really
yeah yeah what'd you write a little
story yeah i wrote a story about uh the
werewolf of i think was called the
werewolf of macon georgia the werewolf
or something like that damn my mama got
the book she got all this i could barely
get through a highlight tonight
kids writing
so i assumed the gpa was good in high
school yeah yeah yeah i graduated like a
4.1
what about the sats oh bro you know
what's so crazy i actually scored higher
on the sats in middle school than i did
when i got older you're one of those
kids that took them younger because you
were sats in middle school my mama had
me in college courses in middle school
yeah
would you get in middle school so when i
was in middle school i believe the
highest score was like
uh was it 15 or 16.
1600 so in middle school i scored like a
1480 whoa
so when i went to uh high school the
highest score was a 2100 and then i
scored like a 1700. but proportionally
right unfortunately that's still pretty
good yeah
you might be the smartest person who's
ever said yeah you might be i think it's
you and uh probably francis ellis
are probably because he likes he aced
his did you go to college yes where'd
you go uh i don't like to name the
universe
no i don't think they like you naming
them yeah it's it's just like it was a
whole acrimonious situation we had bro i
didn't know what that means and they
were uh i wouldn't take it
dropping big words
but uh i do have uh an engineering
degree
yeah okay
well i i don't have an engineer i don't
have it on me but i have a i have a a
bachelor's of science in environmental i
have an environmental science degree
okay and i was going to school to be an
environmental engineer okay so that's
but by the way accomplished yeah i mean
but i went to college for my mom you
know i didn't go to college for me like
when i when i when i went to l.a like
the football career didn't work out i
had a spinal cord injury i had on the
field yeah i had a i had a fractured
vertebrae in my i had a i have a
fractured t-12 vertebrae okay so uh that
didn't work out and i didn't really know
what i wanted to do in my life so i
decided to move to california without
being accepted into any college
so you're 18 you just graduated high
school i grew up in 17. jesus yeah i
graduated 17 about time i was 18. i was
he went for the cia
i graduated 17 by the time i was 18 i
was back at my mom's house and i was
kind of like in limbo about what i want
to do i'm sure
and uh because you wanted to pursue
football in college yeah i wanted to
pursue football in college and while i
was back home i got on uh the show mtv
or mama okay no [ __ ] yeah yeah i was on
mtv on mama's show is that the original
iteration
wow you're perfect for that makes so
much sense so i got on that show and i
had like how did that happen
so um
when i when i uh my my old high school
buddy uh rodney peanut he was my
neighbor also one of my closest names we
lived in the suburbs so neighbors were
you know
half
so uh he was like bro you should do
comedy and i was like how the [ __ ] do i
do comedy like i don't know [ __ ] about
comedy man like
he's like bro just he and at the time
he's like reality tv was just starting
to pop off like in 2008 he was like man
get on he's like get on real world i was
like huh
be like you know real world he's like
you get a real world
so i started going to the mtv website
and trying to just you know apply it for
different things that they had and i saw
that they had a casting call in atlanta
uh so i ended up going to the casting
call and i ended up getting on the show
and then i ended up becoming a writer on
the show okay yeah and then the uh the
head writer i came i wish i could
remember his name because he lives he
lived in new york i don't know if he
this is [ __ ] what 15 years ago yeah
so he lived in new york at the time this
is pre-college or post college well i
did one semester of college and then i
came back home and then i eventually
moved to la where i finished college
okay
so this guy's all over the [ __ ] he
owns properties on yo mama i don't know
what the [ __ ] happening i've lived the
life of a 60 year old jesus christ
do you plan on uh building a house on on
the land that you have in georgia
what are you gonna do with it uh i don't
know that's a good question man uh
probably just give it to my children uh
i don't i don't want to live in my
family okay uh we we we it's
it's uh bro like it's uh
like my granddaddy did a number
on my family as far as the mentality
goes bro and i told my family before i
said look
when when the generation before me
meaning our moms and dads and are all
gone there's not going to be any more
family dynamics so y'all need to work on
fixing something now
because when i was growing up all we did
was have gatherings and now they're few
and far in between mainly when somebody
dies so like i don't really want to live
next to them like i get along
i say you know for face value when they
come to my mom's house when i'm in town
i would get along with them but as far
as like us hanging out or me i mainly
just focus on my mom and my kids like
that's pretty much it and my uncle i
talk to my uncle almost every day there
you go yeah but um
let's talk about ladder ladder let's
talk about the rising cost of living
it's bonkers it's bonkos that inflation
ain't no joke all right do yourself a
favor make sure your loved ones are
taken care of get on ladder get yourself
some term life insurance so you're not
getting buried in the backyard in a
dishwasher box
yeah uh guys ladder is 100 digital no
doctors no needles no paperwork when you
apply for 3 million in coverage or less
just answer one two three four couple
questions about your health in an
application their smart algorithms will
take care of the rest and let you know
in real time if you're instantly
approved no hidden fees you cancel at
any time look at that you wake up you
want to cancel
boom you're right
you get a full refund if you change your
mind in the first 30 days because
they're good people they want to make
sure you're a good fit take care yeah i
want to take care of you um ladders
customers ladders customer rate them 4.8
out of 5 stars on trustpilot and they
made forbes best life insurance list for
2021. look at that i mean forbes forbes
not sports illustrated it's not
highlights good stuff
forbes not maximum uh finally since life
insurance costs more as you age now's
the time to cross it off your list so
here you go baby go to ladderlife.com
garbage today to see if you're instantly
approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life dot com slash garbage
ladderlife.com garbage dad
kev how about that indochino love that
indochino they sent us some stuff i look
pretty fly good stuff your wedding
season is here you don't want to be
showing up like a bozo that's big
talking about custom fitted suits
talking about shirts talking about top
quality product right there do yourself
a favor and get over to indochino yeah
you don't want to show up looking like
you're wearing your dad's suit and
you're trying to [ __ ] defend yourself
in court or something yeah wearing a
dawkins jersey you want to look good and
with indochino you choose every detail
on the suit the shirt the dinner jacket
and more at more more affordable prices
that may surprise you for fully custom
pieces dinner jacket that's clay that's
classy show about a dinner jacket you
want to flex on somebody dinner maybe
throw a crest out of mickey d's really
keep them on their toes uh every suit is
made to your exact measurements and you
can customize every detail create a suit
that fits for you and your style
perfectly with options for fabrics lapel
shape custom monograms statement linings
and more that's real money stuff look at
that a statement line you open it up
you got a picture of kippy right there
uh best part indochino's start indochino
suits start from just 429 and shirts
from 79 bucks and the grand scheme of
things that's all right it's nothing
they offer completely custom fitted
shirts casual wear and more get a
wardrobe personalized to your style and
taste without spending a fortune they
were nice enough to send us a couple of
shirts nice times my going out shirts
well you know lady you're going out i
throw that on i look real nice they feel
cool well that's the carrabbas so have
you got a big day coming up getting the
perfect fit look
getting the perfect look is no big deal
with indochino get 50 off any purchase
of 3.99 or more by using promo code
garbage at indochino.com that's 50 off
your first purchase of 3.99 or more at
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot com promo code garbage
but yeah i got on the mtv on mama show
and the head writer was like you should
do stand-up and i was like huh
i was like bro i know zero about stan
he's like you have good timing he was
like your jokes are like jokes that i
would write and i was like
i guess so we started doing open mics
together in uh atlanta and i did that
for like
eight months and then i did a comedy
competition at the i think it's called
the
punch line yeah with the punch line okay
but it's not like the punch line like
the real ones just like
punch space line you know
it wasn't like the the ones that are
everywhere it's just the punch line in
atlanta it's still it still exists it's
inside of a
diner yeah we just did it not too long
ago but it's not like the official punch
it's not yeah yeah it's like oh that
punch like that that place is awesome
it's like punched space line like the
green room is the [ __ ] lady's office
you know what i'm saying yeah that diner
sweet though yeah it's a good club it
was a good diner uh so i like a hell of
an omelette yeah i placed in a
competition and uh
i placed in a competition i was like i
like i need to like go to new york la
and uh while i'm in macon like macon bro
if you look making up it's a horrible
city it's
like probably one of the worst places to
live like it's nice to me because i stay
out of the way but like as far as the
amount of money you could like if you
want to live good if you want to live in
macon you need to make
uh money that does not come from making
so you need to like have it come from
somewhere else to live because if you
make making a lot of opportunities right
there's not a lot of opportunities so um
so yeah i was in macon and bro i started
getting in trouble with uh i i started
hanging out with this guy named cedric
he had went to prison he was like 23.
and we're going to have to believe that
i don't want to i don't want big said
coming after yeah
uh but yeah we started hanging together
we just started doing like criminal
activity man okay
but you know that's a smart person
within criminal activity yeah man you
know you don't really have it in your
heart you're more of a beta club guy
because you're like and then i got into
criminal activity
this isn't after the mtv right bro this
is i'm doing because i didn't want to
work
what is criminal what in you know in
fictional world what would criminal
activity entail
you could pour that on the table
i don't know if y'all were not trying to
give him promo or whatever
send me back send me cases of this [ __ ]
i don't care so um
he's pouring like we're in a car
[Laughter]
so uh it's under the dashboard
yeah if this was a if this was a movie
and i wanted to add some exciting things
that definitely didn't happen
go ahead
a legend well this is true there was
stop saying
so there was a hurricane in macon uh-huh
and allegedly hurricane lucas come here
and we so we have the cvs we had a bad
hurricane in macon and uh allegedly uh
me and some friends
stop saying you if you're right now okay
yeah allegedly david went into a house
with some friends
and uh was uh i guess you could say
stealing stuff okay okay yeah and taking
it to the pawn shop to get money okay
yeah all right all right so that's
that's that i guess you call it looting
yeah that's not true i think you're
talking about like themis games or
something like that oh no no i mean i'm
being bro i'm a pretty
like i'm i don't take no [ __ ] but i'm a
pretty like
no criminal record type dude yeah yeah
yeah you're just you're you're too smart
for it all right yeah so um
like stuff like that like looting
when an opportunity would arise i didn't
want to work you know what i'm saying
and i and i i had did the mtv thing so
uh you know people thought i was a star
at macon because that's big you know
the the most famous people that we had
for making were like otis reddit little
richard
allman brothers
hello richard david lucas right from
your mama i love it and allman brothers
yeah you know but there were no relevant
like stars sure so like people saw me
and i was the man in the city but i had
no money you're coming out of somebody's
back door with a flashlight holy [ __ ] is
that david
pull my tv down [ __ ] you're on
the tv you're stealing
yeah crusty [ __ ] it did uh
i mean uh allegedly me and my buddy
started going to get um i forget how you
say this type of jury i think it's
called like vermelli
okay it's like silver jury that's gold
plated
gotcha so it would pass the little test
that they would do at the pawn shops in
macon jesus country city so we would go
to atlanta and buy like 200 worth of
this stuff take it back there pass the
gold test
that's smart i like that this is the
beta club yeah here we go so we go back
in the smashing yeah no no smash and
grabs no no i i mean i did you know
but i mean you know looting can get you
chucking a record you know sure which we
did not do by the way it was a hurricane
hurricane the wind took it what do you
want the wind took it so um yeah we
would go buy i think it's called like
vermelli or something like that and we
would go buy this uh gold-plated silver
jury and take it to pawn shops and make
it
and allegedly and allegedly yeah
allegedly we would make a lot of money
you know what i'm saying like buy my own
tv
so all right that became my hustle man
that became my hustle and my mom would
be like where the [ __ ] you getting this
money from now when you were getting the
money were you like using it
conservatively or you're like let's go
get fajitas and margaritas for everybody
any girl that said i was cute i'd take
her out
am i wrestling fajitas my recipe no my
restaurant to go to at that time was
carabas
who are you my mom and stephanie that's
crazy dude i get the chicken marsala
that's my what my mom's been getting for
a decade with the angel hair uh alfredo
oh my god trashy people that's classy
bro that's big that's big time in making
sure
every every dirt ball loves angel hair
pasta
hey like we said making that's high on
the hall
that's high on the hall you know what
i'm saying
we got some country sands out there
that's high on the hog right there
that's high on the hog eat right i was
not i didn't think there even was a
carabao's in georgia that's wild yeah
there's a there's a carabao's in macon
we have a logan's road house we have a
texas roadhouse that makes sense
buffaloes
we got a couple of there's about because
there is old white money in bacon there
are there's like three white families
that pretty much own a great percentage
of all the real estate in macon georgia
and they they they have you know you
know they didn't get that money on the
up and up by the way so i wouldn't feel
too bad right
so we there there is some like it's
almost like uh capitalism in making uh
you you you basically have to have and
have you know you know what i'm saying
there's no middle class in making like
yeah it's rich either you got it or you
don't there's there's no other
option in making there's only two now
when you were growing up if you're like
you know what was where would you go to
dinner if your grand if you know if your
grandfather was taking you guys out what
they would they take out would they take
you out would you hit a carrabbas what
did you hear oh man the the most my
granddaddy ever took me out was we had
this famous hot dog place in macon
called new ways
uh where they sell uh red what y'all
call them up here uh you know what y'all
call glizzies
yeah yeah they sell red lizzies they're
red hot dogs
red hot red hots we would call it but
they're not red hots i know a red hot
dog they're not sausages but they're
that's just i pull it up that's just new
ways like
signature red hot dog okay
that's wild
jesus
oprah went there when she came to make
it
that's real small town [ __ ]
oprah uses toilet i swear to god
like these yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah red hot dogs yeah yeah they're red
hot dogs brothers great food you know
they're great
yeah it's it's some of the best chili
dogs i mean i've had nathan's nature's
cool but yeah they've been sorry new
ways but a small place like that yeah
yeah so you have a lot of like great you
know uh restaurants old school guys
loved hot dogs yeah like our
grandparents so that's that's about the
my grenade was real cheap man very
frugal you know what i'm saying he drove
this old ford pickup truck forever dog
like
at least majority of my childhood to my
teenage years he drove this old two-door
f-150 gray pickup truck that had no
muffler that was loud as a [ __ ]
i can't hear you i can hear it i can
smell it legit we knew when my grenade
was getting off from work because we
knew he was such a tyrant that when we
heard that truck getting off the
interstate we knew we had like four more
minutes
everybody hey turn the tv off shut the
[ __ ] up turn the air conditioner get
your homework out bro in the summertime
this is how cheap my grenade was bro
literally in the summertime he would
keep the air conditioning on 77. and hot
ass makeup
hot ass making today my mom still do
that [ __ ] yeah
with a thermostat my mama's so cheap man
she retired two months ago i said mom
like you legit don't have to worry about
money no more right and she's still i
got carabas for every body
you ride in the back of that pickup
truck all the time man that's you know
what i'm saying we had a garden you know
what i'm saying okay guarding my grenade
with you know like in the south like
y'all got a little bit up here up this
way like people who sell stuff on the
side of the road sure we would do [ __ ]
like that on the weekends like really
like pick the okra pick the collards
pick the tomatoes pick whatever we had
growing at the time and sell outside of
the road yeah farmer's market yeah
pretty good yeah i mean but bro you when
there was no life changing money you
know gotcha it was
you know a good day was if we made 75
and then i get five dollars all right
yeah like what the [ __ ] i mean that was
a lot that was a [ __ ] up margin right
yeah that was a lot of money back then
though you know what i'm saying like bro
like and making right now a hundred
dollars to a lot of money
you might get your wig split over 100 to
make it bro i haven't heard a wig split
in a minute
about to split this [ __ ] away
get your cat peeled
i'll do it all son
that's funny oh that's funny sorry yeah
let's do some garbage let's get into
some [ __ ] questions here baby what we
got
what was the grocery store that you guys
went to when you were growing up
kroger's
pretty legit all right
and piggly wiggly those are the two
giggly wiggly man
she's okay that name kills me i know but
yeah
and the one we went to like with my mom
like when we had special occasions
like when it was new year's thanksgiving
[ __ ] like that because they sell like
all the like grimy meat southerners like
to eat like the fat bag the
the hog mogs they got the sauce meat the
the i don't know what any of this [ __ ]
it all right we
we would go to this real stank-ass uh
ghost store we had downtown making
called jnl
everybody from anybody from macon or
around the area of millersville no the
hell i'm talking just initials is a
tough look
sounds like a rum or something yeah yeah
uh where do you shop now if you go
grocery shopping yeah oh i'm boozy bro
whole foods there you go
whole foods in bristol farms
crystal farms um what was the high
school mascot
so uh i went to uh
i went to uh three different high
schools so uh stratford which was a
private academy okay the strategy
yeah yeah i got a football scholarship
to go there but i didn't get along with
the kids okay uh so stratfor was the
eagles i went to central also central uh
public school yeah it was the chargers
and where i graduated from was rutland
which was the hurricanes
those are all pretty good man standard
names
not too shabby any uh vacations growing
up what a vacation look like orlando
okay yeah would everybody go would your
grandfather go yeah sometimes we'll go
to cleveland we have family in cleveland
we'll go to cleveland where would you
stay when you go to cleveland with them
people house family's
was it was it
was a lake or anything
no they lived in uh warrensville in
cleveland my um who is he to me i think
it's my great uncle
okay
he was a police chief so just from one
suburb to the other yeah there was there
was nothing exciting you know the most i
did growing up was disney world you know
like i i
like how many times have you ever been
to disney world too many like really 12
13 like yeah 12 13 times man like jesus
that was the every year like that was
but but it's right there but okay let me
let me take that back
jesus christ i've never been in my life
we would go to disney world area but we
didn't always go to disney world okay
let me
let me go back we would go to orlando
but we didn't always get a parking lot a
[ __ ] magic kingdom we go we go to uh
universal city walk you know what i'm
saying like city walk is react
buy some fireworks and get out of town
and by time i became a teenager i didn't
really want to go to like because we
would do
depending on who came we would do
something like magic kingdom epcot i
just actually took all the kids to uh
get this to uh disney world like three
weeks ago where that [ __ ] was so
expensive yeah yeah
we're going in two weeks who else went
uh my mom how many kids do you have
three you have three kids so you took
your three kids your mom yeah auntie her
right my brother
and my and my uncle i have a special
needs uncle
she took everybody yeah we gotta way
more than [ __ ] face making some cash
come on man what's up man y'all making
the
money have you ever been given the key
to a city yeah dude this guy's like the
[ __ ] mayor should be running for
office not yet man but uh i don't bro
you know what's crazy
um
i re i tried to get a write-up in the
making newspaper and they turned me down
yeah you're selling fake jewelry all
over town but i mean they didn't know
that
you probably burned them on a pair of
earrings
i gave those to my wife after they
didn't know that she left me were you a
crystal light family growing up
no bro whatever the dollar
whatever whatever the dollar tree
version was i like how you told us that
your grandfather hit you when i said
crystal light that was like a traumatic
experience bro i didn't i didn't drink
kool-aid growing up we drunk flavorate
old flavored stuff no crystal lights at
diet stuff i know what that is but we we
did i'm not asking if you drank kool-aid
what the [ __ ] jesus
erased
we drank crystal light but we drunk the
knockover yeah okay yeah yeah okay
how was your grandmom in the kitchen
good cook my grandma was a great cook
man she was act like
what's so crazy man i only experienced
my grandmama like the full version of
her for like six years gotcha uh before
she had her stroking risk but i have so
many fun memories of her like she was
like she could she looked pretty much
mexican
but she was amazing in the kitchen she
was such a sweet lady i just and i just
have so many great memories of her like
i feel like had my grandma and i had a
stroke i wouldn't be a comedian
because like like
everybody would say like your grandmama
is the only person that kept your
granddaddy in check gotcha you know what
i'm saying so if had she stayed well the
whole time i wouldn't have had the
i know it sounds bad but no about the
drama or whatever oh yeah yeah
i get you from my granddaddy yeah and i
wouldn't have been able you know to
channel this right
sure of course so it was kind of a
blessing in the curse that she had a
stroke in aneurysm but bro she was such
a
sweet strong lady she was married at 16
the first time and then she met my
granddaddy at 19.
yeah man damn that's what's happening
she married a native american who was an
alcoholic and used to beat her ass jesus
she divorced him at 17 then met my
granddaddy at 19.
damn
there you go
this is quite the tail my friends yes
you call your grandfather granddaddy
what'd you call your grandmother do you
have a nickname prayer grandma arena i
guess i don't know why but we just call
her grandma arena
that was her name okay do you have any
uh aunts or uncles that you don't call
by their first name like an aunt cookie
or a uncle i got i i got a uh so on my
dad's adopted so he was oh god this is
something
this is lucas so i know there's going to
be you are a strange mix of crashing
classic i can tell you
buddy i know everything about neutrophil
what do you need to know because you're
a cue ball ain't you baldy but now
there's an answer i know now there's
some light at the end of the end of the
tunnel end of the bald cue ball tunnel
yes sir get a little neutral baby do it
up i know guys uh if you're not familiar
neutral falls a whole body approach to
hair growth no drugs no compromises
you're not smelling with chemicals the
whole nine yards which everybody has
tried in the past okay i'm small like
roundup i know uh there's a holistic
solution for men that promotes both
healthier hair and whole body wellness
nutrifoal is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement clinically shown to improve
your hair growth thickness and visible
scalp coverage take it from me a bald
man okay neutral's hair growth uh has
nutraceuticals go beyond genetics to
multi-target the root cause of thinning
including stress hormones nutrition
metabolism aging lifestyle through the
whole body health takes care
[ __ ] hairline to toenails clean you
up but the main thing is the bald
they're helping you with the bald sure i
don't know why you're rubbing that in my
face
uh nutribull is also trusted and
recommended by more than 3 000 top
doctors look at that include in a
clinical study men showed progressive
improvement in hair growth and thickness
after three and six months whoa there
you go
six months can be a whole new guy you're
looking like harry styles christmas you
come rolling up looking like a [ __ ]
movie star take that uncle john
uh you can grow thicker healthier hair
and support
our show by going to
nutrafull.com and entering the promo
code garbage to save 15 off your first
month's subscription 15 bucks there you
go that's where that's cash money we're
talking now you get a good head of hair
you got 15 bucks in your pocket go out
on a nice date i might rip my hair out
just to save the 15 bucks
this is the best offer anywhere and it's
only available on the two
two u.s customers for a limited time uh
nutrifold.com
enter promo code garbage now back to the
show back to the show so my daddy was
adopted by frank lucas's family
the american father yes was adopted by
frank lucas's family holy [ __ ] yes so
that's how i had the last name lucas
because my daddy is originally cuban
that's how i had the last name lucas so
from him being adopted by frank lucas's
family one of like one of frank lucas's
brothers yeah one of his brothers
adopted my daddy i never met my i never
met my dad's adopted granddaddy but i
have met my other relatives in cuba i
didn't meet them okay or five years ago
uh in cuba mm-hmm
i went down there so uh my dad
um he was like what's going on here he's
being red hot dog he's going to cuba
frank lucas he was he was adopted by uh
frank luke's family and so on the lucas
side i do have family members
in compton and i have a lot there's a
lot of lucas's man uh l.a
texas oklahoma north carolina where uh
frank was from and then he was buried
not too far from here his funeral was
like three three four years ago like a
year before the pandemic he died a year
before the pandemic frank did
and uh you know him uh i met him two
times
and the frank lucas that i met was the
older man i'm sure it wasn't the frank
lucas that they made the movie about
yeah no exactly yeah yeah i didn't meet
that frankly
i met the older in the wheelchair and
i'm still right and i'm still cool uh
with uh a lot of like his direct
relatives that took care of him you know
what i'm saying and i don't really like
throw that around because of course i'm
a comedian not a rapper you know if i
was a rapper oh man if you're a rapper
if i was a rapper that'd be me you
should switch gears your album's called
blue magics
david lucas story
so holy [ __ ] there i actually do have an
auntie in la that i just strictly call
cookie cookie yeah
there you go
and she ghetto as a [ __ ]
she really is bro i can call her right
now
on the podcast i want to hear her
start cursing you out holy [ __ ] uh
growing up did your family keep the
refrig the batteries in the refrigerator
in the freezer dog with aluminum foil
i don't know what that did
nothing
i don't know what that did but yeah in
the freezer with aluminum foil
wow that's great that was buy new
batteries
crazy put them in put them in the foil
have you ever used febreze as cologne
just give yourself a little squirt of
course
of course
and axe body sprays oh man
after you hit puberty
uh have you ever used a coin star
machine for less than twenty dollars
absolutely
i remember my mom used to collect change
and uh this girl want me to take her to
the movies and movie tickets in georgia
i think when i was in high school like 4
25.
so i told her i'll get the tickets you
get the popcorn and [ __ ] so i went and
grabbed like a pocket full of my mom's
change and went to kroger's to go to the
coin store and i think it came to like
13 like yes
dude you walk in feeling like the
biggest piece of [ __ ] you leave feeling
like a kennedy oh man what do you say
what do you know
how do you feel about deviled eggs
are you serious
i'm a southerner for real come on
deviled eggs with some hot sauce
hey shout out to what's that place we go
to
enjoy
okay i love devil days man shout out to
dove telling making georgia they got
some of the best deviled eggs and they
make their own hot sauce and i put that
smoky hot sauce on them man what about
what about fried okra nah i do not like
okay it's too
it's just yeah it's so slimy
i never had it done well where i'm like
oh this was good y'all want to do
something make it i'll hook up something
we gotta we got a new comedy club that's
really i'm i'm gonna be the first act
there because i'm from macon on the 17th
of this month so i'll hook up some with
y'all we are going we're going to be in
atlanta
yeah november november so let's let's do
it to where it you know it may not be as
much as atlanta but
i'll come pick you all up it's an hour
away we do that go eat that doesn't
drive yeah
it's
i'll be staying with you your [ __ ]
grandpa you could you could stay with us
if you want to we're outside cutting the
lawn with a water jug he dropped us off
what the [ __ ]
i'll be back about an hour but i'm one
of those guys man like i don't know bro
like i just feel like um like so
according to history you know history
his story it could be whatever you know
it's something normally orally towed
down
lines but according to uh the history of
macon like macon used to be a very
thriving city because it was uh it's on
the river on the oak monkey river that
runs that runs through macon and it used
to be a very big trade place
and now it's just i wouldn't say shitty
it's trying to come back but i just feel
like a lot of the jobs left probably
with manufacturing or whatever the
shipping i don't know if you ever heard
of browning williamson it was a
cigarette there was a cigarette
manufacturer yeah yeah
they had philip they eventually sent it
overseas to japan right so that was a
high-paying job for a lot of people
making sure and when that closed it's
like you know that was like 15 years ago
like the city took a slow decline yeah
same thing with the automotive factories
in michigan stuff like that yeah so uh
like i'm i'm that guy where i'm like i'm
very making yeah i can tell you're a
champion for the [ __ ] city so it's
like
i can bring something to like i
eventually want to own a high-end club
in macon and i want to own a legit
comedy club but we have a profession
like you want a nightclub like a
bottle service club you mean no more so
like loungy good good food and you can
hear music type that's the frank lucas
in here right there a couple of dry
cleaners
but like so many people in macon will
drive to atlanta to experience something
ambiance and i'm like we can do this
here like you got a heart of gold yes
so it's like i want to do that in making
like yeah i could do it in la yeah i
could do it in new york yeah i could do
in atlanta but man i'm from macon man
like even if i you know like i feel like
rogan about his new club like this is a
passion project
i want my passion project to be in nice
things and yeah that's it i'm putting
bucks county pennsylvania back on the
map
oh you're not far from where shane was
from huh no no no yeah or he was a
little bit the other way but yeah not
too far same
general area
what was your first concert that you
went to
my first concert that i went to was in
middle school i don't know how my mom
paid for these tickets but she did coin
stuff but i went to go see it was b2k
okay corey
uh it was the first time corey y'all
mean i know him i don't know it was a
group called b5 uh sammy and little
romeo which is masterpiece son yeah well
romeo all right oh
[Laughter]
had the first rap snacks i've ever seen
were little romeo i don't know if they
were the first ones yeah that's right to
try to eat twin snacks those are good
yeah who was your mom's favorite singer
teddy pendergrass
teddy peek come on turn off the lights
turn them off
goddamn
um hmm what kind of air freshener you
got in the car none
straight bare bone nothing yeah bro i'm
uh uh
you know not trying to brag i i i mean
like bro growing up in life i rode in a
honda accord most of my life with my mom
and then she got an expedition when i
got like my mom started doing very good
when i got into high school like i guess
all the hard work paid off yeah so she
got a nice car when i was in high
school's expedition and um so i always
have had like a
above average way of life so i i buy
like nicer cars and i like to smell the
weather the leather what are you driving
around in now what do you drive around i
don't want to say really
holy [ __ ] because when we saw you in
texas you were talking about something
getting a new one oh i got that you got
that from that guy yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
all right
kids doing all right that's mine
toyota camry folks i saw that
negotiation go down and it was [ __ ]
crazy
yeah driving
the batmobile that's mine
damn yeah man lucy pay can't pay good
man you know what i'm saying bro shout
out to my best friend lucy
he paid good that's your best friend no
he just did he just did the podcast a
couple of weeks ago and that is a very
classy move
to not say i don't want to say that yeah
i mean but i don't i don't understand he
didn't say the college didn't say the
car but he talks about committing crimes
with half of making so here's the thing
bro like um
i expect it i'm just i don't i don't
like when i was with louie he he told me
bro he said the best thing you can do is
to be a sold out comedy club act he said
once you get to arenas it's not even
about the comedy he said because they're
drinking
they're drinking drinks to see you out
of whatever the local team
mascot is because you're at that arena
and they're watching you on a
screen
the soul of the comedy so you know like
bro i just and you know it makes me stay
humble you know what i'm saying because
i'm still the right i fish bro i put
them i see that i'm a freshwater
fisherman i put on georgia boots and i'm
going fishing tomorrow we're at out
there's a lot of lakes yeah there's a
lot of lakes in jersey so i'm gonna go
fishing tomorrow man and i just want to
stay a common person and be uh relatable
to my audience my my producer for my
youtube clips and he runs my social
medias and everything he calls me the
redneck whisperer
[Laughter]
so you know what i'm saying i want to
always see of course i want to always
seem eye to eye you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah do you know karate
i actually know catch wrestling in
taekwondo
okay you didn't go to like tiger shulman
or anything like that i don't even know
the [ __ ] that is
i don't know no shulman
uh you ever carry a pop carry or collect
pocket knives uh
younger younger yeah i have a gerber now
what's that it's a it's a nice knife
okay
it's probably
about as long as the same uh it's about
as long as the knife that the bodega
owner used to stab that black kid man i
saw that yeah i told i i did another
podcast this morning i was like man you
know that that that potty ca i mean that
uh bodega owner should like
make a brand of knives he should move to
florida he won't poke that guy that guy
that guy [ __ ] up real quick they
should let him they should let him lose
bro like new york he's arrested for
i'm sure it'll be somewhat you know
removed yeah hmm now if you order i'm
sorry if you were to take out food will
you eat out of the container it comes in
a wheat pudding
plate
okay
you're okay with taking leftovers home
from a restaurant no
really i don't like that yes really yeah
it's it's a thing i grew up eating so
many leftovers man like
now
that i'm able to i
it has to be something very good okay
you know what i'm saying like even if
you don't finish it leave it whatever i
mean bro that's what i'm saying you
think i'm not finished
my leftovers are not that much so that's
probably why you know even if i don't
like it i'm finished i'm not taking it
but um you want to wrap up this parsley
i'm always arguing my mom about that
[ __ ] man like bro i buy new food
okay all right
anybody in your family have a birthday
on a holiday
any christmas babies absolutely who do
you got
my girl
okay okay she's halloween
okay that's not too bad halloween's all
right and i'm three days after christmas
that's not bad on christmas horrible
christmas fourth of july still why do
you feel you got ripped off yes bro you
get one present for christmas and your
birthday
that's your big present now that's for
both right yeah yeah there you go merry
christmas happy birthday
uh have you ever saved a crown royal bag
nah my mom does yeah but she use them
for anything specific
dude changing the crown royal bag just
it's different yeah i don't know are you
a hellman's man or miracle whip
uh and do you [ __ ] with mayo i
i do [ __ ] with mayo bro i do but i like
light mayo on my sandwiches and okay i
have to say i'm hellman's good i don't
like that sweet [ __ ] no
miracle is trash believe me you answered
correctly
have you held
in your hand in the last 365 days a
turtle or a frog
damn right
both why
where so uh my
light mayo ain't going to save you now
so i like i told you i got my kids for
the summer sure i i haven't been to my
house in l.a in like six weeks okay
because most of my shows are on this
side of the united states right right
now uh so uh me and my daughter went
frog hunting we went gigging
for frogs like two weeks ago we're at in
georgia in my mom's backyard bro like my
mom's backyard dog is
yeah it's the woods you know what i'm
saying so we went gigging for frogs and
i fish a lot so every time i hook
turtles up all the time okay yeah that
makes sense that makes sense we eat at
the counter the diner you counter guy
hell yeah okay
yeah yeah yeah i don't know i don't know
what it it's it's just so dope eating
somewhere where you could just ask the
person right there all the time hey can
i get the uh yeah yeah of course
you have to wait for them to walk by uh
do you know anyone who ever worked at a
hooters
yes
friend family member it was a girl i
went to high school with okay
uh she was a year or two older than me
she was a cheerleader and me and my boys
in high school thought it would be you
know taboo like let's go to hooters get
some wings you know
and she was working stacy what the [ __ ]
are you doing yeah she was working like
like that and making like because it's a
very conservative might as well been a
hooker yeah
macon is a very conservative
city so a lot of the girls that worked
at the hooters like may have lived in
like one of robins or 30 minutes out
like they didn't live in macon so when i
saw her i'm like what though what are
you doing working at hooters
you're a good christian guy enjoy going
to hell
grab me some more blue cheese
holy [ __ ] uh do all the pillows in your
bedroom have pillowcases on them
bro i ordered them long-ass pillows
and i don't even know how to order
pillowcases for that
put a pair of sweatpants on it
[ __ ] that's dressed up like a scarecrow
that's my number one fight oh me and my
girl actually got into a fight about
that before i came here the pillow
because uh the house that i rented uh
the ladies said
if there's makeup or anything on my
pillows
uh you won't get your security deposit
back she said so [ __ ] airbnb
got a lot of [ __ ] balls so uh she uh
wrapped it up in a brick so p this is
how what she this is
i'll tell you so this is how much she
doesn't value [ __ ] that i do for her i
just bought her a brand new shirt it's
like a hundred dollars okay so she
wrapped the pillow that she sleeps on
and this brand new shirt and i'm like
what the [ __ ] are you like get one of
those cheap ass fashioned over shirts
that you
bought with your own money and wrap it
down and wrap the pillow with not this
120 shirt i just bought you
and i was sleeping on it today she's
like why are you on my pillow
you're nasty
you've been out walking the streets of
new york why are you laying on my pillow
she's so [ __ ] like put the deposit
down
yeah i paid for this airbnb [ __ ]
you sleep with your socks on
got them right you do yeah what do you
sleep in i sleep in uh
i i wear like uh the breathable boxers
so all my boxers are like quick dry
gotcha you know what i'm saying those
type of coming back quick try like
shamwow what are you talking about like
like you know like not like the
old-school boxer material no it's like
you go to nike and order their nice
stuff
yeah they're dry fish it's like spandex
so i sleep in that in socks because you
just never know when you need to get up
and [ __ ] get out of there you know
what i'm saying bro
i'm still glad it's gonna come inside
i'm still black bro i'm still blacking
it the other day you living in cleats
you never know when you need to get up
and get up out of there
i never sleep naked bro cause that's too
much to put on bro i can throw a shirt
on my sock my shoes by the bed so i can
put on a pair of shoes and get a body
there man like you keep your shoes by
the bed absolutely that's why i can't
and at my house i keep my gun in my bed
my gun is in the arms reach that i can't
[ __ ] i understand that in l.a in l.a i
live in west hollywood one of the gayest
neighborhoods but still brothers
you guys i'm sure you grew up shooting
and stuff like that when i was a kid
right
just different daddy i killed my first
turkey when i was like eight turkey
and the bad part the y'all might not
notice the bad part about turkey try to
sell me bad jewelry
the the bad part about turkey hunting is
that uh so deer don't see in color so
you can you can wear the orange vest
where you're hunting deer turkey seeing
color
so you can't wear the orange vest
okay so that makes you at risk sure
you know of getting shot so bro like tur
i i i prefer not the turkey hunt but
you know i'm not trying to get what
you're shooting turkey with a game gun
or a rifle no you got to shoot turkey
with a with a shotgun brother
i don't know
yeah yeah he was talking about his name
glock 9. get on your knees [ __ ]
[Laughter]
busted out of turkey i know frank lucas
did you eat the turkey when you when you
killed it
good turkey yeah absolutely bro there's
nothing like fresh kill bro like fresh
hog
you go kill a wild pig that's
that's you've done that absolutely
and the thing about the thing about like
wild pigs bro is like they have a lot of
armor
so there's like a small
there's are they in jail yeah that's a
dragon
it's their rib cage you know what i'm
saying they have like a uh
it's almost like they evolved to not get
shot okay and they're actually very
dangerous man yeah no i know so like
they have a very small area that you can
shoot them in bro but that's some of the
best
like some some wild some wild pig ribs
some wild sausage that sounds good
it's very good man you know like i'm
from jordan we smoke a whole hog baby
we smoke a whole hog bro dig a hole
overnight that whole overnight that
any any deer deer steaks oh my god oh
venison's awesome yeah bro dear steaks
i've ate possum raccoon
squirrel fried squirrel oh man thank you
you you're starting out real good yeah
you're thinking i don't care what
[ __ ] club you're running junior
[ __ ] bragging about fried squirrel
you're a dirtbag squirrel steaks y'all
everybody alligator i've had alligator
once i've had kangaroo ostrich alligator
i wasn't crazy about hanging around joe
rogan
yeah yeah of course
yeah yeah this question has only been
ever asked to ari shafir uh but if you
were overseas would you eat dog
yes
i've had rat i went to nagasaki japan i
had rat
damn but it was covered in so much sauce
i didn't know if it was bad or good
sure you know like it was it was so
saucy i don't like i'm like i don't know
if this is good or bad like
i didn't know like it was tasting the
sauce yeah it was so saucy like you
don't have teriyaki on it you're already
doing anything crazy like to eat the pig
snout and stuff like that are you using
i would back in the day but now like
you're clear yeah yeah like i don't eat
pig feet no more really i don't really
eat uh like nick i don't eat like i
don't eat none of that slave food like
we call it back home like you know like
like black people got the leftovers man
you know we got the shots and [ __ ] like
if i'm not if i don't got a lot of money
the minimum i'm gonna get is a chicken
breast you know what i'm saying
i draw a line at some point all right
uh
in l.a where do you keep your butter in
the fridge or on the counter
i keep my eggs in butter on the counter
eggs on the counter no i don't i don't
frizz on my eggs you're getting fresh
eggs then yeah i bought fresh air whoa
you don't got to put them eggs in the
refrigerator if they've been treated you
have to treat it yeah i buy them you buy
brown eggs yes that are probably
untreated syrup you keep in the fridge
or in the cabinet cabinet ketchup i
don't eat ketchup really i hate ketchup
wow that's interesting yeah
what about mustard you like mustard yes
huh love me some mustard uh
like dijon depending on what i mean if
i'm eating like a charcuterie reward
i'll indulge in some
dijon guy walks in both worlds
he just dropped if i'm having a
charcuterie board i'll have great boubon
i'm like bro i'm the guy who will eat a
plate of gator or i'll go eat filet
mignon wagyu with you yeah okay you know
you know
pretty crazy how do you feel about
tapping up a papioca pudding hate it
okay good answer you're running a cruise
absolutely
you have a mouse wall a mouthwash cup in
the in the no sir no mouthwash have you
ever you don't use mouthwash
you floss
occasionally okay whenever i eat a steak
when's the last time you're at the
dentist
dentist yeah
five months ago four five months ago
really damn
i'm trying to work on where i'm missing
like three teeth i'm trying to i missed
a two in the back yeah yeah i've been on
dentist like 20 years yeah but it takes
me [ __ ] 45 minutes to eat a
filet mignon
do you have name brand luggage
uh yes will you take your shoes off on a
plane i do all the time i know i i try
to um
i try like i'm one of those people who
like you know i hate when i see people
flying and they go for the design over
the comfort
you know what i'm saying because i can't
fly first class all the time i'm right
i'm just gonna be honest yeah i can't uh
so like if i'm especially in coach bro i
go for the like slip-ons the flip-flops
the crocs the yeezys i can take them off
very easily okay the the basketball
shorts and the sweatshirt that's that's
my normal
flyer tire like i don't care about what
y'all think i got on like i'm trying to
be comfortable yeah will you put the
seat back in an airplane all the time
i do it before takeoff
as soon as as soon as the flight intend
to sit down i break all the rules take
myself
as soon as as soon as as soon as the
pilots say uh flight attendants prepare
for takeoff i'm like oh hell yeah here
we go let the seat back take your
seatbelt off the speakers come out
um anyone in your family ever represent
themselves in court
um
probably my brother's daddy okay
all right he was a career criminal
at some point
yeah yeah if anybody had to probably
save a couple of bucks did you know
anybody that was on the show cheaters
anybody on the local news
absolutely okay my granny was on local
news yeah yeah yeah
four
it was the anchor
he did weather
there was there was something happen
there was something that happened in the
area where he owned some homes it was in
the ghetto and they interviewed him for
something and he looked like a complete
idiot did you guys all watch everybody
he made everybody stay up to 11 00
o'clock to i'll be on the news tonight
he made everybody stay up there
he made all of us stay up to watch that
[ __ ] that's awesome that's what i'm
talking about i think i only got one or
two more here hmm
[Music]
do you have you ever owned your own pool
cue or bowling ball
really
i'm a big pool player really i love them
growing up in my granada's house he had
a pool table really so i was very good
at pool i don't i i don't you know how
it is we don't have the opportunity to
do much that we used to enjoy like the
only show a lot of the activities yeah
the only thing i find time for now is
the gym in fishing but like pool
it's like a
once every two week thing now like if i
see a pool table i'll go shoot but i
used to be a very avid pool player huh
did you name the poor queue no okay
do you name your cars they have names
uh when they were raggedy i did not know
that's cuter yeah that's cute
and now it's just like [ __ ] you better
crank up you yeah you got too
but you know you got it right come on
sally come on baby
come on baby got it girl come on baby we
go we gonna make it
up
come on you got one more in
here yeah that's awesome have you ever
owned cargo sweatpants of course oh
that's a bad luck well you put gum under
a table all the time
have you ever smoked wheat out of a soda
can
no
i have oh yeah me too i smoked it out of
an apple yeah that's you know yeah
that's healthy it's organic
i like it
have you ever saved a cigar box for
storage
yes but they were cuban cigars
so
passports
i put all of my cuc which is the form of
currency in cuba in there see you soon
see you see cook or cup cup so cuc is uh
the the mode of it's the cuc is the
currency for
uh everybody
cup is strictly like cuban the cuban so
i get both of them because my family's
cuban so i get that i get c-u-p and
c-u-c cash i don't [ __ ] around down here
how many times you've been there
cuba probably like six times damn mm-hmm
i honestly i'm out i'm not i've
what are you saying here i'm saying it's
a proper coin it's a proper write down
in the middle and he's had some of the
trashiest wildest answers and also
some of the most yeah i'm the best of
both worlds christine you know what i
mean i can't say you're trash i can't
call you definitely not class
you have some classy tendencies
yeah
i was talking about [ __ ] pickling
hogs feet or whatever reason no but the
hell of a family lineage
yeah yeah yeah my family lenny is bro
and we're doing like [ __ ] jewelry
scams city to city yeah stuff
he's hitting a [ __ ] bubble tape jewel
right now what flavor is that freaking
writer's tears out of a solo pretty much
right
watermelon bubble gum i knew what it was
i'm black man
he's blowing puffers too yeah yeah no
regard for the smoke alarm
buddy
right down the middle corner yeah right
there from both worlds 50 50. but it's
incredibly [ __ ] interesting you're
incredibly [ __ ] awesome
[ __ ] so happy to have you here
i love y'all man how about this podcast
is so funny how about that i was uh
immediately attracted to these guys no
homo the first time i met him yeah they
won't kill tony and uh dude i i i used
to watch kill tony a lot and i saw you i
mean he would eviscerate
to the point where like
you could see they'd be like oh i could
hang and they'd do a couple of lines and
then like even like people i'm friends
with i'm like man you don't want to do
it yeah and then he would just [ __ ]
torture him
when we did kill tony we were sitting
there and you came on and then you two
started going back i told him i told
foley i said yo follow the doll we can
rip and stop i said when he gets on
stage it's his [ __ ] i got under the
table
like an air raid siren went off i was
like dude i don't want this smoke at all
i didn't make eye contact
i'm just sipping bud lights dude
good stuff you're on tour right now yeah
yeah what do you got coming up uh let me
let me shout out some of my dates right
quick hold up please for sure check him
out he's like absolute killer of a
[ __ ] killer
like i'm not even gonna like i don't
know if y'all feel this in comedy but
sometimes you don't feel worthy like you
know what i'm saying you go to a show
you're like damn all these people showed
up to see me it's awesome yeah so
july 29th through the 30th i'm at mike
drop comedy in san diego august 12th
through the 13th i'm at uh upstage
comedy lounge in san antonio september
the 2nd through the third i'm at wise
guys in vegas september the 14th i'll be
at mcgoobies in baltimore maryland
september movies september the 18th
sandman comedy club in richmond virginia
december the 16th through the 17th i'm
in tampa florida at side splitters and
there you go it's not updated on my
website now but i believe it's november
the 22nd
through the
26th or 25th i'm in winnipeg
okay there you go at whatever comedy
club that is in in canada so yeah buddy
you're killing it man congratulations i
loved having you kippy what do you got
for him uh we're all we're all over the
road we're announcing
the links in the description check us
the [ __ ] out uh the shows are selling
out especially in the bigger market in
the big cities they're funniest kids
thank you buddy we love you gang we love
you and we'll see you next week peace